[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
C Chatelin bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous député de liser président du
groupe écologiste à l'Assemblée
nationale on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par Julien l'Écuyer de la
voie du Nord bonjour Julien bonjourian
bonjour Mame bonjour on va dire un mot
ce qui se passe du côté du remaniement
pour commencer c'estel châelin puisqu'on
a appris hier soir par lui-même que
François Baayou n'entrerait pas au
gouvernement il acte un désaccord
profond sur la politique à suivre est-ce
que pour vous on est dans une querelle
d'ego sans conséquence ou la majorité
est fragilisée aujourd'hui on l'avait
dit en décembre la loi immigration
marquait la fin du en même temps je
pense que c'est sa concrétisation donc
oui c'est une je pense c'est
profondément une Clarelle politique la
fin du en même temps c'està-dire ça
marque une droitisation pour vous bah
bien sûr on a Rachid qui rentre au
gouvernement on a un gouvernement qui
est extrêmement à droite on a un Premier
ministre qui fait une déclaration de
politique générale qui finalement
reprend quand même par exemple sur
l'éducation un certain nombre de
propositions en tout cas de conception
du du rassemblement national dans ses
dans ses prises de position on a un
gouvernement qui a repris des
propositions programmatiques du
rassemblement national et qui l'a mis
dans le texte de loi immigration oui
c'est c'est une droitisation et c'est
même un glissement vers une droite
radicale il a parlé d'humiliation vous
comprenez ce terme oui je comprends ce
terme parce que non seulement on est
finalement pour moi dans un gouvernement
qui est incompétent ça fait 30 jours
qu'on a pas de ministre du Logement
alors qu'on a une crise sans précédente
on a un effondrement de la construction
on a des personnes qui n'arrivent même
plus à louer on a 8000 personnes qui
chaque soir n'ont pas de réponse du 115
on a pas de ministre du Logement il y a
christopre Béchu qui a le logement sous
sa responsabilité je sais qu'ils ont une
espèce d'idée qu'il y a des surhommes
qui peuvent tout faire en fait la
question c'est est-ce que les syndicats
est-ce que les associations est-ce que
les les les acteurs de la construction
du milieu HLM ont un interlocuteur je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il peut pas tout
faire il peut pas faire et les
transports et le logement et la question
climatique enfin ça n'existe pas et par
exemple le transport c'est d'autre sujet
on a des projets de rare métropolitain
qui sont bloqués dans les territoires on
a toujours pas l'interlocuteur donc déjà
il y a pour moi quand même une profonde
incompétence et la deuxième chose sur
l'humiliation c'est moi j'ai
l'impression un président qui finalement
est dans une espèce de jouissance de sa
toutepuissance là ça fait un mois que
c'est lui qui décide c'est lui qui
décide qui rentre qui sort à quel moment
on fait les annonces donc je pense
vraiment qu' qu'il est dans c'est pas un
peu le cas à chaque fois c'est le
président qui décide de la composition
du gouvernement pas pendant 1 mois il y
a eu un peu une crise agricole quand
même mais ça peut jouer ben normalement
la crise agricole arrive déjà plusieurs
jours semaines après l'annonce de
Gabriel hatal donc on voit bien que
après que le président a pris le temps
de se mettre en scène pendant 2 heur
avant même que le premier ministre a
fait son discours de politique générale
donc on voit bien où on est dans un
moment où le président se sait central
c'est qui peut gérer sa majorité et donc
en fait il prend son temps mais il prend
son temps au détriment de l'avancement
des politiques publiques et justement on
a une crise agricole avec un
gouvernement qui est à moitié au complet
est-ce que si comme vous le dites la
majorité est fragilisée aujourd'hui il y
a des conséquences politiques qui
doivent être tirées pour
vous personnellement moi si j'avais euh
le chef de mon parti qui parlait
d'humiliation oui j'en tirerai des
conséquences politiques ben déjà
peut-être alors moi personnellement
c'est un gouverne de majorité dans
lequel je serai jamais rentré mais une
fois qu'on y est il il y a plusieurs
options il y a soit vraiment on claque
la porte puis on dit ben écoutez si vous
avez besoin de nous ça sera au cas par
cas parce que finalement les lesé
ministes modemes doivent quitter le
gouvernement il y a pas de logique il y
a plusieurs il y a plusieurs options il
y a soit vraiment il y a l'option
maximale qui est dire on s'en va on
claque la porte va faire comme les LR on
va gérer au cas par cas finalement ils
ont plus de pouvoir que nous c'est une
option la deuxième option c'est de dire
B on reste quand même mais on va montrer
les dents un peu c'està- direire qu'on
va arrêter de devoir tout valider parce
que il y a une solidarité
gouvernementale en fait s'ils
considèrent aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
humiliés que le PACT qu'ils avaient en
terme d'équilibre politique n'est pas
respecté ben s'ils veulent qu'ils soit
respectter il faut qu'à un moment il
metettent du poids dans dans la balance
et je pense qu'il y a des sujets sur
lesquels nous on peut les aider à mettre
du poids sur les questions démocratiques
sur les questions de la proportionnelle
même sur les questions du logement je
sais opportunité pour vous ben en fait
moi je leur dis à un moment si ça
balance à droite vez faire rééquilibrer
en fait la question de l'équilibre
politique on a 150 députés de gauche on
n'est pas d'accord on n pas le même
projet de société ils sont rentrés dans
une majorité dans laquelle nous on n'est
pas rentré mais il y a des sujets par
exemple on parlait des collectivités
territoriales les transports au sein des
collectivités teritoriales je suis sûr
que c'est des chès sur lesquelles on
peut trouver un point d'entente pour
faire avancer ces projets là développer
les transports en commun développer le
Ferré c'est enfin le train en fait ça
vous dit au députés modem venez
travailler avec nous oui c'est le
message que vous leur en fait je leur
dis si vous voulez rééquilibrer venez on
peut TR créer une nouvelle majorité
oui alors là on sera peut-être un peu
trop à gauche pour eux mais libre à eux
de changer d'amis Julien autre question
majeure pour ce ce nouveau ce casting
final c'est la présence ou non d'Amélie
et UDA Castera on sent qu'elle est très
fragilisée semble-t-il que le Emmanuel
Macron a pris la décision de de la
cantonner au sport et aux Jeux
Olympiques on parle de Nicole Boubet
pour la remplacer à l'éducation
nationale qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
elle aurait dû quitter le gouvernement
il y a bien longtemps quand je pense que
c'est une ministre qui bien sûr n'a plus
aucune crédibilité sur la question
éducation mais au-delà de ça je pense
que c'est son éthique qui est mis en
cause finalement quand on on est pris à
mentir pour justifier des choix
personnels ça pose question sur sa
pratique de la politique donc elle doit
même quitter le portefeuille des sport
pour vous oui pas uniquement l'éducation
nation mais en moi je je je je sais pas
mais en fait il y a une question de
d'intégrité propre c'est dire que quand
je suis ministre depuis un mois que
finalement j'ai été prise à mentir qu'on
voit que j'ai des pratiqu qui vont à
l'encontre de ce que du portefeuille que
que je devrais avoir des valeurs que je
devrais B j'en tire la conclusion que je
ne suis pas à ma place au sein du
gouvernement elle aurait dû quitter le
gouvernement depuis longtemps et sa
crédibilité elle est entachée sur le
sport
aussi le nom de Nicole Boubet comment
vous réagissez l'ancienne garde des
saut moi la question c'est qu'en fait
c'est pour mettre en place et je pense
que ça sera le cas la politique annoncée
par Gabriel Atal on sera en désaccord
profond je pense que c'est une politique
qui va creuser sur l'école mais oui mais
sur quoi précis par exemple je prend
exemple des groupes de niveau on sait
que ça va on a un Premier ministre qui
nous dit l'école ça doit être finalement
l'égalité pour tous et en fait on fait
des groupes de niveau dont on sait que
ça va creuser les inégalités scolaires
nous on a eu une réunion dans mon
département fair comment ça allait se
mettre en place maintenant des groupes
de niveau il nous disent en fait c'est
des groupes pour des élèves fragilisés
donc il y a des collèges où il y aura
pas de groupe de niveau il y a des
collèges où il y aura des groupes de
niveau donc ça veut déjà dire qu'on aura
déjà en fait dans la perception des gens
deux niveaux de collège puis au sein des
collèges gr élèves en difficulté ils ont
besoin d'ê en plus petit groupe
justement pour mieux apprendre et pas
être dans des grandes cl aujourd'hui
c'est la enfin les sciences de
l'éducation montrent que ce qui
fonctionne c'est l'émulation collective
c'est aussi l'entraide qui peut y avoir
entre les élèves mais vous avez
l'impression que ça fonctionne
aujourd'hui quand on voit le niveau des
élèves dans les classements internation
mais ça fonctionne pas parce que ça fait
des années qu'on a un gouvernement qui
ne parie plus sur l'éducation nationale
qui à l'inverse justement et dans cette
logique de de concurrence en fait entre
les élèves qui les poussent à la
concurrence et qui n'a pas justement
parier sur les questions de donner les
moyens aux professeurs d'être dans des
groupes effectivement des groupes
classes plus petits mais mélangés en
terme de niveau enfin on n' pas on s'est
pas appuyé sur la liberté pédagogique
des enseignants qui connaissent leurs
élèves on leur donne peu de moyens on
donne moins de moyens au collège en
difficulté que dans les collèges en en
enfin où il y a des élèves qui vont
potentiellement mieux donc en fait oui
on a un souci de répartition des moyens
dans l'éducation nationale et de
confiance dans les équipes éducatives
Julien on va parler d'un autre on va
parler de l'hommage national hier aux
victimes du Hamas exactement hommage aux
42 victimes françaises des attaques du
du du 7 octobre Emmanuel Macron a-t-il
eu les les bons mots lors de cette
cérémonie pour vous
c'était c'était oui il a eu un beau
discours et c'était une cérémonie
extrêmement émouvante c'était je pense
c'était un moment important de
d'ommage d'unité céit un moment solennel
donc oui c'était euh et est-ce que vous
avez compris la la réflexion de des des
députés insoumis qui ont malgré tout
malgré les critiques et les demandes de
plusieurs familles de leur non présence
est-ce que vous avez compris qu'ils soi
quand même présent oui c'était un
c'était un hommage républicain et je
pense qu'il était important que
l'ensemble des familles politiques
représenté soit là euh en fait pour
rendre hommage ensemble euh à ces
Français victimes des attaques ne vou
pas de leur présence mais alors oui il y
a des familles qui ont parlé enfin moi
je respecte la la voix du deuil enfin je
pense que ils sont dans une peine que on
ne peut pas imaginer c'est François
Ruffin excusez-moi François Ruffin qui
estimait que les parents qui pleurent
leurs enfants ont tous les droits de
signifier que il faut entendre leur
douleur et donc respecter leur leurs
demandes mais bien évidemment ils ont en
fait ils ont tous les droits de la
manière dont eux souhaitent vivre ce ce
euhette tragé par contre par contre nous
étions dans un moment et donc c'est pour
ça que moi je et vraiment je respecte
cette parole et et je l'entends mais là
on était dans un hommage national
c'était la nation avec l'ensemble de ces
composantes qui rendaient hommage à des
Français victimes des attentats du 7
octobre je pense que ce moment d'unité
il était important madame ch en fait la
question je vais la poser autrement si
imaginons dans un monde hypothétique des
des familles vous avez demandé de ne pas
être présent pour une raison X Y vous
n'auriez pas voulu vous-même ne
respecter cette cette demande moi je
encore une fois je dis j'entends la
demande des familles la vérité
aujourd'hui c'est que ces demandes là
elles ont été instrumentalisées elles
ont été politisé par toute une partie
des membres du gouvernement par une par
toute une partie des membres de la
majorité dont l'objectif n'était pas de
respecter le souhait des famille mais
qui était finalement de continuer un
discours qu'ils ont maintenant depuis
plus d'un an qui serait que le groupe de
la France insoumise serait finalement
hors de l'arc républicain c'est
absolument faux la France insoumise est
un parti républicain nous étions dans
dans un hommage républicain de
l'ensemble de la nation où l'ensemble
des députés étaiit conviés donc oui ils
avaient leur place en tantés c'est le
gouvernement qui a demandé aux familles
de demander à LFI de pas venir non c'est
pas ça que j'ai dit j'ai dit qu'ils
avaient instrumentalisé les propos j'ai
je n'ai absolument pas dit qu'à un
moment ils avaient demandé aux familles
qu'une fois que la parole a été posée on
voit bien qu'il y a des élus politique
dont la porte-parole du gouvernement qui
ont eu là des paroles qui étaient
politiques on n'est pas sur des
personnes qui sont dans la douleur on
est sur des élus politiques un
gouvernement qui ont fait le choix de
faire un hommage national qui ont fait
le choix de convier l'ensemble des force
politique à cet événement et qui après
disent non mais il y en a une partie qui
doivent pas venir en fait ça c'est pas
possible c'estd que on est
dans n' jamais n'a jamais dit que les
députés et les filles deventils les ont
invité oui mais c'est ce que je disais
ils les ont invités et après on a des
membres de la majorité on a la
porte-parole du gouvernement qui dit non
mais effectivement il ferait mieux de
pas venir en fait si on est sur un hmage
républicain sur on est un moment
solennel de la nation un moment
justement où on se dit que la perte
qu'on a eu elle est tellement grave elle
est tellement forte qu'on doit être dans
un moment de rassemblement et bien on
est sur un rassemblement de l'ensemble
des composant de é dans cette même
démarche dans la marche contre
l'antisémitisme voulu par yel brun pivé
par Gérard Larcher qui se voulait aussi
un moment de communion de tous les
représentants de la nation elle est fi
refusé d'y participer est-ce qu'il y a
pas un paradoxe alors on est alors
c'était un moment extrêmement important
et je pense que la question de la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme doit absolument
nous nous rassembler nous unir et les
mots qu'a eu le président de la
République hier sur cet antisémitisme
rampant cet antisémitisme qui tue était
extrêmement important d'ailleurs je
pense et je continue à penser que
c'était extrêmement important que toutes
les composantes de l'Assemblée soit
présente pour soutenir ces motsl prè sur
la marche on était sur un moment
important mais on était pas sur un
hommage national après c'était une
marche publique sur lesquel les
personnes étaient libres ou pas de
choisir le fait de venir mais moi je et
en fait moi ce qui ce qui m' triste et
je veux quand même le dire c'est que euh
là on a parlé beaucoup de qu'est-ce qu'
a dû faire qu'est-ce qu'aurait dû faire
la France insoumise enfin et on a peu
parleré de l'hommage on a peu parler en
fait des victimes de la jeunesse de ces
victimes moi j'été frappée je le savais
mais de voir ces images de voir les
photos ça m'a rappelé à quel point ils
étaient jeunes de voir les familles moi
ce que j'ai trouvé extrêmement fort hier
c'est c'est de enfin on a eu le le le
départ à la fin des photos et les
familles ensuite et il y avait ce
moment-là où en fait enfin en vrai moi
je pense qu'on s'est tous reconnu dans
leur douleur on l'a tous vécu en tant
que famille et justement je pense qu'on
est dans un moment qui est tellement
clivé qui est tellement violent que
parfois on a besoin de se rappeler non
mais la question de la compassion
j'entends est essenti dernière question
sur sur ce sujet c'est que l'élisé
évoqué le projet d'un temps mémoriel
pour la mémoire des victimes des
bombardements à Gaza c'est une bonne
initiative il faut le faire ça aussi oui
c'est c'est une initiative c'est une
initiative importante aujourd'hui on a
des milliers de victimes on a
potentiellement des centaines de
victimes qui seront victimes des
bombardements ou de la fin on y a un
grand danger je pense ce temps mémoriel
il est important et il doit êre de la
même manière unir tout le monde on a
parlé de la crise agricole tuens Marc
fen le ministre de l'agriculture était
auditionné hier à l'Assemblée oui il a
défendu la la mise sur pause du du plan
écofyo alors je vous demande pas si vous
êtes en accord avec cette mise sur pause
parce que je pense connaître déjà la la
réponse il a quand même eu cette
réflexion il a jugé qu'on pouvait pas
faire peser sur les agriculteurs
français plus d'exigen que sur les
voisins européens il veut trouver des
indicateurs communs pour éviter la
surtransposition c'est pas une bonne
initiative
ça la première chose c'est pour nous
dans les demandes des agriculteurs
extrêmement fortes il y avait la
question du revenu c'est dire
aujourd'hui il ne peuvent plus vivre de
leur travail on apporte à ça une réponse
qui est la fin euh de l'interdiction des
pesticides c'està dire non mais pas
vraiment ça mais oui non mais
globalement on avait le plan écopyo non
mais je je sur simpimplifie mais on
avait le plan écopyo qui vise à baisser
de 50 % la pratique des pesticides donc
d'un côté on agriculteurs qui disent on
narrive plus à vivre de l're travail et
de l'autre côté on a gouvernement qui
dit vous inquiétez pas on va arrêter un
plan qui vise à mis sur semaines il y a
ça il y a le fait que vous avez vous
avez raison il y a la question
évidemment des des revenu c'est la loi
de la loi égalime mais les les
agriculteurs sur le terrain font tous
part de la la complexité et surtout la
le déséquilibre entre les exigences qui
qui leur sont demandé et celles pour
leurs voisins mais je voudrais quand
même finir sur le plan écopito parce que
bien qu'on a dit 3 semaines moi j'ai eu
des échanges avec les membres de
majorité qui m'ont dit de toute façon on
arrête on arrête t ceux qu' toutes
les je sais pas si ça prendit mais les
signaux que j'ai moi me laisse plutôt
penser que on a un gouvernement qui va
dire s'il y a pas eux s'il considèrent
qu'il n'y a pas de remp Clement ou
produit oui ça sera arrêté moi les sign
que j'ai c'est plutôt ça donc oui on a
une vraie inquiétude sur le fait que ça
soit pas 3 semaines d'arrêt sur le plan
écophyo mais que ça soit un arrêt enfin
sinédié un report sinédié ou finalement
ça s'enterre et pourquoi je voulais
quand même revenir sur ce sujetl parce
que parce qu'en fait quand vous dites
normes sur transposition le gouvernement
dans sa bouche dans la communication
qu'il en a fait c'est les questions
environnementales et c'est notamment la
question sur la lutte contre les
pesticides et je voulais faire le lien
entre le revenu et la question des
pesticides parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui
on a une expérimentation dans les deux
sèves sur des centaines sur des milliers
pardon sur des milliers d'hectares sur
des milliers d'hectares où on a
justement appliqué le plan écophyo
c'està-dire qu'on a réduit de 50 %
l'utilisation des pesticides donc
aujourd'hui on sait ce que ça donne et
bien la vérité c'est qu'il y a pas eu de
baisse de rendement ça c'est la première
chose c'està dire que quand on baisse de
50 % l'utilisation des pesticides il y a
pas eu de baisse de rendement et la
deuxième chose c'est que comme on achète
moins au début de pesticid et que ça un
coup et bien en fait par hectare c'est
c'est 200 € de plus pour les
agriculteurs ça veut dire que si un
agriculteur a 100 hectares de de culture
ça lui fait 20000 € de plus par an vous
dit aux agriculteurs c'est qu'il il se
trompe visiblement c'est
Quever je dis que le gouvernement se
trompe et en fait a pris une décision
qui lui paraissait facile mais qu' ne
répond en rien à la demande des
agriculteur la deuxième chose sur la
question mais donc je pense c'est
extrêmement important de rappeler qu'en
fait ce plan écofito ne s'oppose pas au
revenus des agriculteurs et même de
l'expérimentation qu'on a dans les deux
sè c'est l' plus la complexité et le et
plus c'est pr même d'indicateur la
deuxième chose effectivement il y a
cette complexité mais je enfin
aujourd'hui ne soyons pas DUP c'est pas
là-dessus que le gouvernement appuyé la
deuxième chose gouvernement dit on le
met en pause pour retravailler les
indicateurs donc il met quandême en
pause la question pas qu' de concurence
déloyale mais la deuxème chose c'est sur
la question effectivement de de la
difficulté et
de de de ce qu'on a enfin de règles qui
peuvent paraître absurdes et je pense
qu'ils ont raison moi je suis allée dans
un barrage en iser ce don ce dont on
parl les agriculteurs c'était par
exemple le fait qu'ils étaient contrôlés
par satellite c'estàdire que sur pour
les aides de la PAC tous les trois jours
ils font des photos satellites des
parcelles et si la couleur de la
parcelle correspond pas à ce qui est
planté on demande aux agriculteurs
d'aller prendre une photo et de pouvoir
prouver qu'ils ont bien planté alors et
par exemple ça donc c'est pas les éc qu'
demande ça n'a rien à voir avec le planc
le phyo par contre oui je trouve que ça
ne fonctionne pas qui a des contrôles
pour tout le monde bien évidemment c'est
normal par contre là oui effectivement
il faut pouvoir demander qu'on contrôle
autrement c'est là on fait passer une
pression donc il y a des discussion mais
moi je vois pas le rapport entre fait
questionner et nous même on veut
requestionner la pack parce qu'on pense
qu'elle n'est pas distribuée de la bonne
manière mais questionner ça et mettre en
pause le clan hpopito qui en fait
emporte des dangers de santé public
majeur Julien Gabriel est dans le Pas de
calis aujourd'hui oui il est dans ma
dans ma région au chevet des des
sinistrés et les beaucoup surveillent
les les nuages au-udessus d'eux près de
60 million d'euros ont été débloqués
jusqu'à présent pour la reconstruction
un plan de résilience face aux aléas
climatiques aussi est en cours de de
rédaction est-ce que c'est suffisant
selon
vous la PR chose c'est je pense
qu'effectivement c'est absolument
nécessaire que l'État soit au côté des
des personnes sinistrées c'est des
inondations à répétition moi j'ai eu des
amis qui habitent là-bas il n disent
mais vous rendez pas compte plus c'est
l'hiver donc il y a l'inondation il y a
de l'humidité dans
les dans les
murs c'est en train de craquel enfin
donc oui il est absolument indispensable
que l'État soit là pour bah pour faire
face et pour protéger face à ces
inondations en répétition après moi il
me manque une chose dans ce que vous
avez dit c'est la lutte obstinée et
déterminée contre le réchauffement
climatique mais ce qu'il va sûrement
dire dans son discours ce soir non mais
en fait enfin ça c'est faux c'està dire
qu'en fait le président l'a déjà dit il
a dit il y aura rien de nouveau le
Premier ministre l'a redit dans son
discours de politique générale il nous
disent il y aura rien de nouveau donc en
fait on a un problème il dit on a agi on
a baissé de 5 % les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre l'année dernière oui mais
alors c'est typiquement cet exemple mais
qu'on a eu un débat il est en fait
comment dire il est biaisé c'est-àdire
que quand on regarde la décision du
Conseil d'État le Conseil d'État dit
effec que les mesures structurelles pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique ne sont pas suffisantes et
que oui il y a une baisse des émissions
mais qu'elle est dû à des des critères
conjoncturels c'està-dire deux choses le
fait que les prix étaient élevés et le
fait que l'hiver était dou ça veut donc
dire que cette baisse elle n'est pas du
à la politique d'Emmanuel Macron et donc
finalement l'entendre dire un
satisfaisis sur les questions
climatiques alors que leur politique est
insuffisante c'est pas possible donc moi
moi je pense que oui il faut être au
côté des des victimes des inondations
mais en fait on peut pas juste leur dire
vous inquiétez pas on va faire un prend
de résilience et puis on sera là dans 3
ans si ça recommence on doit leur dire
on met tout en œuvre pour lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique et diminuer
en fait les risque de répétition
d'intempérie oui mais ça c'est plus sur
des dizaines et des dizaines d'années on
le sait le changement climatique c'est
surtout qu'il faut un plan de
financement aussi parce que ça nécessite
des transformations vraiment radicales
même du cadre de vie mais alors oui faut
un plan de financement il y a eu des
rapports qui montrent que les besoins
financiers sont importants d'ici à 2030
en tout sur des financements publics et
privés on est à plus de 60 milliards
supplémentaires par an donc c'est des
sommes qui sont colossales la bonne
nouvelle c'est que cet argent il est là
et il existe par contre ça veut dire
mettre à contribution ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont les premiers profiteurs
de la crise climatique je prends un
exemple total total hier a annoncé plus
de 20 milliards de recettes de bénéfices
bé
voilà c'est ça 19,8 près de 20 milliards
globalement en fait total c'est une
machine à cash sur le pétrole et sur
notre capacité à vivre demain il faut
aujourd'hui qu'on arrête cette machine à
cche dire que il faut les REM prenre cet
argent le remettre au pot commun pour
permettre la sortie des fossiles les
fossiles c'est 90 % des émissions de CO2
donc aujourd'hui on a une entreprise qui
fait des profits sur notre capacité à
vivre demain et on les met pas à
contribution c'est en fait c'est pas
acceptable donc cet argent il là sauf
qu'aujourd'hui il va dans la vente dans
la poche des actionnaires qui en fait
Paris sur en fait la vie des personnes
qui aujourd'hui sont en train d'avoir
moi je sur total puisque vous en parlez
parce qu'il y a une commission d'enquête
qui a été mise en place ici par les
sénateurs écologistes par vos collègues
sur total et Patrick Pouan le PDG total
il se dit choqué qu'on utilise les
moyens de l'État pour faire une enquête
sur la stratégie d'une entreprise privée
quand
dites-vous je dis que quand cette
entreprise finalement bénéficie euh d'un
soutien de l'État euh que on a bénéficié
pour se développer continue à en
bénéficier parce que on sait que Total
fait partie des entreprises qui font
partie de la diplomatie économique
française quand cette entreprise met en
danger notre capacité de vivre sur Terre
oui c'est normal et c'est le rôle des
élus de faire une enquête sur leur
pratique termine par de la politique
Julien oui européenne allez allez bon
Marie tousin votre candidate je suis
bien désolé de vous le rappeler mais ne
décolle pas vraiment dans les sondages à
à l'heure actuelle est-ce que c'est un
problème de de candidat ou de stratégie
alors moi déjà je veux lui redire toute
ma confiance je pense que c'est une
eurodéputée qui est fait un travail
fantastique on est encore très loin des
élections et je suis persuadée que elle
décollera et donc non ce n'est pas un
problème candid non mais en fait
qu'est-ce que je moi je vous me demandez
non mais non je pense que ce n'est pas
un problème de candidate je pense que
Marie toussin de par son parcours elle
incarne à la fois un engagement total
sur les questions environnementales et
un engagement extrêmement fort sur les
questions de lutte contre la pauvreté et
de lutte contre les inégalités et je
pense que c'est ce dont on a besoin donc
aujourd'hui on est en début de campagne
on a une vague réactionnaire sur toute
l'Europe on a une attaque contre les
écologis pas seulement en France mais
partout en Europe donc on savait que la
campagne serait pas facile et moi je
suis extrêmement fière d'avoir une jeune
femme qui est là qui est déterminé qui
commence à faire campagne qui est sur le
terrain et donc je pense que là
aujourd'hui on pose les d'une campagne
qui va se déployer dans les mois qui
viennent un dernier men oui Adrien
catenin c'est hier qui faisait son grand
retour sur les plateaux de télé le
député etfi regretter les ambitions
personnelles et politiciennes qui
empêchent une liste commune aux
européennes ça vous fait sourire
oui pourquoi pourquoi bah je pense j'ai
pas le son de moral à recevoir d'Adria
catin voilà ça permettez de vous poser
la question vous avez été choqué par ce
retour
médiatique c'est un retour bien organisé
de communicquant voilà moi je je
j'espère qu'il est sincère j'espère
qu'il a compris le fait que ça soit
tardif met quelques doute merci cel
châelin merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité la une de la voie du Nord c'est
sur gabrielal dans le pcal C inquiétude
des et les témoignages des sinistrés qui
ont qui craignent les suites à chaque
alerte on a peur c'est le titre de la VO
du Nord merci Julien merci beaucoup on
passe au club des territoires